Transcription: Clara Manisier
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour. Oui, vous, bonjour !
Vous avez été tiré au sort pour participer
à la Convention Citoyenne pour le climat.
Votre mission, si vous l’acceptez :
trouver des solutions
à la crise climatique,
tout en étant juste socialement.
Cet appel, des milliers de personnes
l'ont reçu en juillet 2020.
Certains ont d’abord cru à une blague,
à une arnaque, à une farce.
D’autres, au contraire, ont cru
qu’ils venaient de gagner au loto
et ont tout de suite dit oui.
D’autres, souvent des femmes,
souvent des jeunes,
ne se sentaient pas légitimes,
avaient besoin de réfléchir,
de voir avec leur famille, leurs proches,
avec leur employeur aussi.
Et puis certains, des
climatosceptiques, se sont dit :
« C’est la chance de ma vie,
je vais pouvoir montrer au monde
à quel point ça sert à rien de lutter
contre le changement climatique. »
Au final, ils étaient 150 à accepter.
Des jeunes, des vieux, des riches, des
pauvres, des Noirs, des Blancs, bref,
ce que les sondeurs appellent
une mini France.
Une mini France à la rescousse du climat.
Neuf mois plus tard, à la fin des travaux,
il y eu des réactions très différentes,
comme deux camps.
Un camp très nombreux qui saluait
leur travail, applaudissait.
Entrepreneurs, syndicats, ONG, chercheurs.
Et même citoyens français qui
plébiscitaient l’ensemble de leurs mesures
à l’exception d’une seule.
Et puis, l’autre camp, le camp des
sceptiques, ceux qui, peu nombreux,
mais très vocaux,
critiquaient cette expérience.
Aujourd’hui, ce que je vous propose,
c’est de faire un retour en arrière.
Pour vous expliquer,
vous raconter ce qu’a été
la Convention Citoyenne pour le climat,
et ce qu’on peut en tirer pour
l’avenir de notre démocratie.
Nous sommes à l'automne 2018.
Le mouvement des Gilets jaunes
vient d’émerger en France.
Moi, à ce moment-là, j’ai 28 ans.
Je suis militante pour le
climat et la démocratie.
Au moment où les Gilets jaunes commencent
à occuper les ronds-points,
je bosse sur un projet de vidéo.
Une vidéo qui va vite se faire connaître
parce qu'elle va permettre à la pétition
de l’affaire du siècle
d’avoir un retentissement.
Deux millions de signataires,
la plus grosse pétition de France.
Elle vient donner une caisse de résonance
à un recours en justice
déposé par quatre ONG qui attaquent
l’État pour inaction climatique.
Ces quatre ONG, Greenpeace, Oxfam,
Fondation Nicolas Hulot,
Notre Affaire à Tous, sont reçues par le
Premier Ministre suite à cette démarche.
La réponse est simple :
« Bravo, vous avez fait
un super coup de com.
Surtout, c’est une magnifique réponse au
mouvement anti-écolo des Gilets jaunes. »
Quand on me rapporte cette réponse,
j’ai le bide noué.
Pour moi, c’est la pire chose
d’opposer écologie et justice sociale.
J’ai l’impression qu’on utilise le travail
auquel j’ai contribué
pour mater un mouvement que je respecte.
Parce qu’en parallèle,
je vais de rond-point un rond-point avec
d’autres amis, de Démocratie Ouverte,
une association dans laquelle je suis
engagée depuis quelques années.
J’essaie de comprendre,
juste en écoutant, en observant,
qui sont, qui est ce mouvement
des Gilets jaunes.
Je me lie même d'amitié avec certaines
d'entre elles, ces femmes en jaune.
Jusqu'au jour où je rencontre Agnès.
Gilet jaune.
Qui, un jour, m’a sciée
en me disant cette phrase
en explosant en sanglots :
« J’aimerais être comme toi.
J’aimerais être écolo.
J’ai trois gamins, et le poulet Lidl
à la fin du mois,
je peux pas m’en passer
pour les faire bouffer.
Même si je sais que c’est de la merde. »
Ce jour-là, je me suis promis
de faire tout ce que je pouvais
pour ne plus jamais entendre ce genre
de phrase dans notre pays.
Parce que pour moi, ce n’est pas normal
que des gens aient à faire le choix
entre le poulet Lidl à la fin du mois
ou la question écologique.
Quelques jours plus tard, on se rassemble.
Gilets jaunes, militants écologistes,
acteurs d’innovation démocratique.
On n’a pas encore le nom, mais le
collectif des Gilets Citoyens est créé.
Ensemble, on va tâtonner, on essaie
de trouver ce qui nous rassemble,
ce qu’on peut faire ensemble pour montrer
que cette opposition entre fin du monde
et fin du mois, elle est dépassable.
Très vite, on se rend compte que c'est la
question démocratique qui nous rassemble.
Qu’on soit Gilets jaunes ou qu’on soit
militants écolos, on en a tous ras le bol
de la manière dont la politique se
fait aujourd'hui dans notre pays.
On veut que ça bouge.
Alors ensemble, on écrit une lettre
ouverte au Président de la République
et on demande la mise en place d’une
assemblée citoyenne tirée au sort
traitant de trois sujets :
Transition écologique, referendum
d’initiative citoyenne,
une grande demande des Gilets jaunes
à l’époque, et la justice fiscale.
Pour être honnête, à ce moment-là,
on se dit : « Bon, ça va être comme d’hab.
On écrit un truc,
mais il ne va jamais la lire.
Donc on continue à travailler. »
On se dit : « Si on doit mettre en place
nous-mêmes cette assemblée citoyenne,
comment tirer au sort les gens ?
Sur quels critères ?
Comment et quels intervenants choisir ? »
On commence même à lever un petit budget
jusqu’à ce que Cyril Dion, qui a
rejoint les Gilets Citoyens, m’appelle,
et me dise qu’il a décroché
un rendez-vous à l’Élysée.
À ce rendez-vous,
il va convaincre le Président de mettre
en place une telle Assemblée citoyenne
et de nous rencontrer pour voir comment
on met en place une telle assemblée.
S’ensuit un certain nombre
de rendez-vous là-bas.
Ça, c’est l’Élysée.
Je n’y avais jamais mis les pieds.
C’est doré, grand, haut,
c’est impressionnant.
Pour être très honnête, pour moi,
c’est un autre monde.
C’est un monde dont je me méfie.
Un monde où je me dis, est ce qu’on va
pas se faire avoir ?
Après cinq, six réunions,
on décortique le processus,
on met en place des lignes rouges.
Pour chacune d’entre elles,
on se retrouve avec tout
le collectif des Gilets citoyens.
Et on pose nos lignes rouges,
y compris dans la presse,
pour éviter de se faire avoir.
Même si on a des amis au sein du ministère
de la transition écologique et solidaire,
on se méfie vraiment beaucoup.
Au final, dans les conversations, l’Élysée
accepte toutes nos lignes rouges,
sauf deux.
La première, c'est le niveau d'ambition.
Nous, on partait du constat scientifique,
donc ce qu’on voulait,
c’était une réduction d’au moins 50%
des gaz à effet de serre
dans un esprit de justice sociale.
Donc on a dit ça,
et nos interlocuteurs ont souri
en nous disant :
« Écoutez, dans la loi aujourd’hui
en France, c’est -40%.
On n’arrive même pas à le faire ! Alors on
sait que les scientifiques disent -65%,
donc, ça, c’est hors de question. »
On a trouvé un terrain d’entente et on
s’est dit que si on laissait les citoyens
choisir par eux-mêmes, on pouvait leur
donner comme mission de réduire
d’au moins 40% les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d’ici 2030,
dans un esprit de justice sociale.
La deuxième chose que l’Élysée a refusée,
c’est l’idée d’avoir automatiquement
un referendum
à la fin de la Convention
Citoyenne pour le climat.
Et pas un referendum comme les autres,
un referendum à choix multiples,
à questions multiples.
On ne voulait pas un referendum
« oui ou non »,
où les gens répondent
oui ou non au Président de la République
selon qu’ils l’aiment
ou qu’ils ne l’aiment pas.
On voulait un referendum
où les gens répondent à la question.
Il y a des centaines de pays où
cette pratique référendaire,
avec des questions différentes le même
jour, permet d’avoir le point de vue
de l’ensemble de la population réelle
sur des questions données.
Le Président de la République préférera
s’engager à passer sans filtre
l’ensemble
des propositions de la Convention,
soit au Parlement,
soit à la voie référendaire.
A la fin de ces échanges,
on hésite beaucoup.
Est-ce qu’on s’embarque
dans cette aventure ou pas ?
Et on finit par dire oui, même si on doute
sur l’engagement du Président ;
est-ce qu’il veut
vraiment tenir ce « sans filtre » ?
On s’engage parce qu’on se dit que c’est
une occasion unique de montrer
que des citoyens tirés au sort
peuvent écrire la loi.
4 octobre 2020.
Les 150 citoyens tirés au sort se
réunissent pour la première fois au C2.
Moi, je suis un peu comme celui au milieu,
j'ai la grosse banane,
je les trouve trop beaux.
Je les trouve tellement beaux
que j’ai versé
ma petite larme de joie ce jour-là.
De voir une assemblée aussi diverse, avec
autant de femmes, autant de jeunes.
Je n'ai pas pu, dans ma tête, m'empêcher
de comparer avec l'Assemblée nationale.
Quand on regarde ces deux images,
on voit bien qu’il y a un problème
dans notre démocratie.
Je ne dis pas que
nos élus sont tous pourris.
Je suis pas du tout dans ce courant-là,
même plutôt contre.
Je pense que la majorité d’entre eux
essaient de faire
leur boulot correctement.
Le problème, c’est les règles du jeu.
Quand on voit ces deux images,
on voit bien qu’il y a un problème
de représentation dans notre pays ;
qu’à l’Assemblée nationale, les jeunes,
les femmes et les classes ouvrières
et populaires sont sous-représentées.
Lors de cette session, les 150 citoyens de
la convention vont se prendre une claque.
La claque d’un diagnostic scientifique
qu’ils méconnaissaient.
Valérie Masson-Delmotte, du GIEC,
va leur présenter ce que disent
les scientifiques du monde entier.
Beaucoup d'entre eux n'avaient pas
conscience du niveau d'urgence.
Beaucoup d’entre eux n’avaient pas
conscience du niveau d’impact
du changement climatique.
C’est la claque, l’électrochoc,
un énorme sentiment d’impuissance.
Une baffe, c’est ça les mots qu’ils ont
à la fin de la première session
de la convention.
À la fin de cette première session,
dans l’équipe d’organisation,
on n’en mène pas large.
On se dit qu’on n’est vraiment
pas sûrs qu’on va y arriver.
Est-ce que, vraiment, des citoyens
tirés au sort peuvent écrire la loi ?
Est-ce qu’on ne s’est pas plantés ?
Est-ce qu’on est pas en train de
faire un truc complètement fou ?
Deuxième session de la convention, les
citoyens sont répartis dans cinq groupes.
Se nourrir, se loger, se déplacer,
consommer, produire et travailler.
Ils auditionnent un grand nombre de gens
dans la règle de ce qu’on appelle
le débat contradictoire.
Concrètement, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ils ont des gens pas d’accord entre eux,
pour pouvoir comprendre
les différents points de vue
et mettre, eux, le curseur au bon endroit.
Par exemple, dans le groupe Se Nourrir,
à la deuxième session,
il y avait à la fois
un acteur comme Carrefour,
un acteur comme la FNSEA,
syndicat agricole majoritaire
qui n’est pas connu pour être très allant
sur les questions environnementales.
Et Greenpeace. Trois acteurs
pas du tout d’accord sur ce qui bloque,
ce qu’il faut débloquer,
et comment on y va.
Session trois sur les solutions, pareil,
un grand nombre d’intervenants
et vous voyez là, ils ont en tout eu
une centaine d’intervenants,
la répartition des typologies
d’intervenants
et vous voyez à quel point
elle a été diverse
pour prendre en compte non pas juste
ce que disent les scientifiques,
mais la complexité de mettre en œuvre des
solutions face au changement climatique.
A la fin de la troisième session,
on commençait à voir
ce qu’est l’intelligence collective,
à le sentir.
Ça peut paraître un mot valise, mais c’est
justement un niveau de maturité du groupe
qui commençait à se connaître,
mais aussi d’expertise.
Aucun d’entre eux n’était expert de la
question climatique à ce moment-là. Aucun.
Mais ensemble, ils avaient un niveau
d’expertise extrêmement élevé
et d’ailleurs beaucoup
d’intervenants me l’ont dit.
S’ensuivent d’autres sessions,
quatrième, cinquième, sixième,
où ils débattent, pas toujours de manière
fort agréable entre eux,
mais facilités par des professionnels,
pour aboutir finalement à 149 mesures
qu’ils vont pouvoir présenter
au Président de la République.
149 mesures.
Notre président de la République ne va pas
retenir grand-chose finalement
dans la loi qui sera présentée,
actuellement en débat au Sénat.
D’ailleurs, les citoyens de la convention
vont dire qu’ils ne sont pas contents
et qu’ils trouvent que le Président
n’a pas tenu son engagement
de passer sans filtre leurs mesures
au Parlement et à la voie référendaire.
Ça, c’est les résultats des votes
des 150 citoyens tirés au sort,
à la question « Quelle est votre
appréciation de la prise en compte
par le gouvernement des propositions de la
C.C. pour le climat ? »
3/10.
Certains y sont allés de
leur petit commentaire.
« Le président de la République s’est
piégé en faisant cette convention.
Il avait complètement sous-estimé ce que
des citoyens étaient capables de faire. »
D’autres ont préféré en rire
avec ce type de caricatures
où même Brigitte dit que le bulletin
d’E. Macron sur la convention est pas top.
3/10 pour le président de
la République,
mais 8/10 sur ce à quoi sert et ce qu’est
le recours aux conventions citoyennes,
est-il de nature à améliorer
la vie démocratique de notre pays ?
Pourquoi une telle note ?
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire
sur ce que la convention citoyenne
apporte à notre démocratie ?
Trois choses. La première, c’est que le
tirage au sort apporte un nouveau souffle
à notre démocratie parce qu’il permet
l’intelligence collective.
Parce qu’il permet de mieux
représenter les femmes,
les jeunes et les classes populaires,
toutes les personnes sous-représentées.
Mais aussi parce qu’il permet
de penser long-terme.
Quelqu'un de tiré au sort n'a pas
la pression de la réélection.
Il n’est pas obligé de montrer
ce qu’il a fait en cinq ans,
il peut penser à 10, 20 ans
un certain nombre d’actions.
Deuxièmement, le tirage au sort n’est pas
incompatible avec le système électoral.
Un certain nombre
de citoyens tirés au sort
étaient abstentionnistes
quand ils sont arrivés à la convention.
Aujourd’hui, beaucoup ont
retrouvé le chemin des urnes.
Certains vont même se présenter
à des élections régionales.
C’est ça aussi, la force du tirage au
sort : de ramener à la politique des gens
qui n’en peuvent plus de la manière
dont la politique classique se fait.
Enfin, ce que la Convention dit de l’état
de la démocratie, c’est aussi une dérive
vers un système oligarchique
où quelques-uns,
assez puissants, assez riches,
ont un pouvoir beaucoup plus important
que le reste de la population.
Ce constat-là, Nicolas Hulot l’avait fait
quand il a démissionné,
quand il a demandé qui a le pouvoir de
décider en montrant du doigt les lobbys.
Àu moment de la Convention,
l’Observatoire des Multinationales
a rendu un rapport assez glaçant sur les
pratiques qui ont été mises en place
pour dézinguer les propositions
de la C. C. pour le climat.
Pour convaincre nos élus de ne pas voter
un niveau d’ambition aussi haut,
pour mettre en cause votre avenir,
mon avenir sur la question climatique.
Ce n’est pas une fatalité
et c’est ça le message
que je veux vous passer aujourd’hui.
C’est trop facile de dire : « La politique
ne m’intéresse pas, c’est chiant,
je ne comprends rien
à ce qu’ils racontent ».
Il y a un adage qui dit :
« Si tu ne t’occupes pas de la politique,
la politique s’occupera de toi. »
Du coup, avec des amis, on a décidé de
poursuivre et d'aller un cran plus loin.
De proposer aux prochaines
élections présidentielles
de redonner la main aux citoyens, en
mettant en place une primaire populaire.
Mais une primaire différente des autres.
Une primaire qui part des idées, des
propositions qui vont changer nos vies.
Une primaire où ce ne sont pas
les partis politiques qui décident
qui sont les candidats,
mais c’est nous, citoyens,
qui pouvons proposer des noms.
Une primaire où on ne vote pas
pour le moins pire,
ou contre celui qui nous fait
vraiment très peur,
mais où on vote pour quelqu’un.
Aujourd’hui, à vous de choisir.
Est-ce que vous voulez être
dans le camp de ceux
qui regardent une démocratie mourante
et sont de simples observateurs ?
Ou est-ce que vous voulez être acteurs
d’une démocratie vivante demain ?
A vous de choisir.
(Applaudissements)